the world of Ice and Fire
is a world of mystery and lost history a
world of wonder and terror and magic or
dragons White Walkers and Wars make
their homes it is a world of cruelty and
beauty and injustice throughout the eons
their tales of kingdoms rising and
falling great heroes against impossible
odds and darkness that is absolute and
consuming in the world of Ice and Fire
even the seasons battle for dominance
but is there purpose behind the chaos of
this world what voices whisper in the
dreams of our characters nudging them
pushing them into their destiny and what
voice speaks from the flames and to sea
and the island and the trees in this
video I will attempt to answer these
questions if you look closely just about
everywhere in the world of ice desire
can be found an eerie black stone in the
jungles of sepharose lies a ruin said to
be older than time or even the green of
the earth theorists read it is made
entirely of the black stone with blocks
so large that it will require dozens of
elephants to maneuver a GaN sister-wife
Nymeria calls this place a city so evil
that even the jungle will not enter and
every attempt to rebuild or we settle
this place has ended only in grief and
horror this place is called een on the
Iron Islands
it is unknown where the sea stone chair
came from it was discovered by the first
settlers of the isle and they took it as
their throne it is made of the same
black stone at battle Isle the base of
the high tower is also made of his stone
again its origins are unexplained even
the reason behind the name of the Isle
has been lost to the ages the 5/4 of ye
t stand guarding the empire from what
lies beyond the frozen gray waist again
it's origin and purpose are lost and
shrouded in legend and mystery there is
the idol of Toad Isle that is worshipped
by the locals there and there is of
course the ancient city a shy that is
built from the ground up of the same
strange and eerie stone all of these
objects have in common that their
origins are lost the time they seem to
be relics of some old forgotten
civilization a kingdom that inhabited
from the shores all the way to the edge
of Asus into the heart of darkness what
happened to the beings that built these
artifacts and where are they now they
seemingly had vanished leaving only this
black stone I have speculated in the
past that the Deep Ones of Lovecraftian
fame were involved this idea was
proposed by master fairy on of the Iron
Islands who claimed that both the sea
stone share and the base at battle Isle
was created by these seeds Welling
entities though the legends of the deep
ones and the Merlin's are prominent in
Westeros especially amongst the shore
dwelling people I now suspect there is
far more involved some of the oldest
stories in Westeros come from the golden
Empire of UT whose fabled lands were
ancient even before men took absorbes
against the children of Westeros their
legends speak of a prosperous place
where civilization thrived and people
lived harmoniously under the rule of the
dawn emperor and according to legend
rather than die he ascended into the
stars
it is now my belief that as he ascended
something else fell to the earth it was
the black stone meeti fell into chaos
the black stone consumed the mine of the
bloodstone Emperor and he slew his own
sister and ushered in the greatest
darkness that this world has ever known
because with the coming of the black
stone came the other
not the frozen white walkers of legend
but the other deities from the stars I
am proposing that the dawn emperor of
Legend was indeed more than a man but
instead a long-lived being from beyond
the stars and at the end of his
Millennia's long reign he ascended back
into the heavens and others saw the
vacancy that he left and they swarmed
this was the coming of the great old
ones for ten thousand years the great
Empire of the dawn flourished in peace
and plenty
under the God on earth dominion over
mankind then passed to his eldest son
who was known as the Pearl Emperor yet
every reign was shorter and more
troubled than the one preceding it for
wild men and baleful beasts pressed at
the borders of their great empire if you
are confused allow me to explain in the
work of Lovecraft from which Martin
borrows heavily there are a slew of
entities which were said to inhabit the
earth long before mankind they were
numerous and diverse in temperament and
form they were beings from the stars of
unimaginable power but not true deities
although they were worshipped by many
human and non-human coats they are known
as the great old ones as we eons past
they fell into deathlike sleep where
their interactions with mankind are
limited generally imprisoned beneath the
sea inside the earth in other dimensions
they'd interact with men through dreams
and suggestion and Blackstone the most
famous of these beings would be Cthulhu
who sleeps dead dreaming beneath the sea
in his house at relay Cthulhu whispers
to the minds of humanity spreading chaos
and anxiety as some of you may know the
religion of the drowned God which is
prominent in the iron islands of
Westeros is in many ways inspired by the
worship of Cthulhu what his dead may
never die
is merely a play on a saying by Cthulhu
worshippers
many times in our story you may notice
characters seem to be pulled into
incredible circumstances Danny after
many mysterious and terrifying dreams
manages to perform ancient magic which
allows for the birth of her dragons it
is almost as though the knowledge was
planted into her head in my
understanding the birth of Dragons video
I identified two distinct wills being
imposed upon her one seeking to birth
dragons into the world add one seeking
to prevent them and the lure of loved
craft the gods are often at odds with
each other using mortals as pawns in
their greater games often through dreams
as I mentioned before we witness in a
game of Thrones the battle for Danny's
mind neither of these forces is
necessarily good or evil they simply are
impartial an ongoing theme of A Song of
Ice and Fire is that the High Lords play
their game of Thrones and the common
folk beneath them suffer I put forth
that there is another game being played
a game that makes the game of Thrones
look like child's play it is the game
for Dominion of the earth the religion
of the red God tells the tale of two
beings locked in eternal conflict
opposing each other each with mortal
servants on earth in earlier videos I
had compared these entities to have star
the unspeakable one whose name lacks the
great other is not to be uttered and
Cthulhu like the lore and the great
other they oppose each other fiercely in
the winds of winter in a dream brought
on by the shade of the evening the wine
of warlocks are young Greyjoy sees his
brother Euron as the Lovecraftian god
Cthulhu sitting upon the iron throne
with all the other gods of the world and
paled dead upon it he saw his brother on
the throne again but Euron was no longer
human he seemed more squid than man
a monster fathered by a cracking of the
deep his face a mass of writhing
tentacles the bleeding stopped he spoke
at the end he said to Aaron these are
the last days when the world shall be
broken and remade a new god shall be
born from the graves and
so according to urine a new God shall
rise to claim the world and in doing so
the world shall be broken just as it was
after the bloodstone Emperor brought
about his reign of terror on the world
leading to the long night and according
to the people of the further east the
world has been a broken place ever since
george RR martin has thrown elements of
cosmic horror into his story and they
can only aid to the bittersweet ending
that he is teased at the irrelevance of
mankind is a common theme in all of
Lovecraft's work while we are so focused
on who wins the Iron Throne we may be
thrown for a loop when none of it
matters at all
Euron said the bleeding star we spoke at
the end but not the end of time only the
end of their world as they know it
something fundamentally changed in their
world today the Comets elf magic
returned to the world though many
readers and many characters in our story
contribute this to the Dragons Danny
sees the bleeding star in a game of
Thrones before the dragons are born so
if anything it was the comet that led to
the birth of the Dragons not the other
way around in HP Lovecraft's the colour
from outer space a meteorite crashed
from the sky it poisoned every living
being near it animals are driven mad and
deformed into grotesque shapes
vegetation was foul-tasting and inedible
and the people would go mad or die off
slowly what crashed was something beyond
the scope of human understanding
something truly alien the effects of the
meteorite the inability to grow food the
foul undrinkable water the animals that
die mysteriously when brought near it
are all problems also found in ash I the
ancient city made of black stone which
sits just southwest of the heart of
darkness where at its core exists the
guy also referred to as the corpse city
Corp City is a reference to relay and
Lovecraftian lore which is also referred
to as the Cork City relay is the home of
the great old one Cthulhu it is said
that Cthulhu aged dead dreaming and when
he wakes from his slumber he would
reclaim the earth for his own spreading
despair to the inhabitants of the world
it would be quite odd indeed his real
Lovecraftian deities inhabited the world
of Ice and Fire
and I am NOT suggesting that they do but
what I am suggesting is that similar
beings in nature indeed do lurk among
four lesser beings of this world
inspiring religions such as the worship
of the lore or the Black Goat were the
pale child it is no coincidence that
your own speaks of the comic when
speaking of the coming of this new God
the bloodstone emperor of UT was said to
worship a stone that fell from the sky
the stone even though it corrupted him
gave him immense power
Geron himself seems to defy what many
believed to be possible he has sailed to
Valyria and returned with various
artifacts including the dragon binder a
full suit of Valyrian armor which no
other on earth possesses and possibly
another which has gone unnoticed by most
although it's hidden in plain sight a
piece of the comet while under the
influence of the shade of the evening
the damp hair sees his brother Euron in
valyrian armor but he also sees
something that few others have Euron's I
he showed the world his blood I now dark
and terrible it is immediately after
this that Euron mentions the comet so
here are the connections blood I sounds
a lot like bloodstone we know that ye
T's bloodstone Emperor worship to stone
that fell from the sky we know that the
red comet was seen throughout the earth
but is it possible that it crashed if so
then where perhaps the place where no
man could look Valyria
but Euron defied this he sailed to old
Valyria
he found the comet he commune with the
Fallen God and became its thrall and now
he where as a piece of the comet within
his empty eye socket and the entity sees
through him in exchange for power
Iran has agreed to serve the will of
this entity in the same way that
bloodstone did in the winds of winter
Iran appears to be performing strange
and cruel rituals
could they be similar to the dark
rituals performed by the bloodstone
Emperor all those millennia ago
bloodstone was said to be the leader of
the Church of the star wisdom which is
again another Lovecraftian reference in
Lovecraftian lore members of the church
worship the hunter of the dark another
malevolent deity the Song of Ice and
Fire is a game and planet tous is the
playing ground
Euron represents the coming of its
newest player the lives of the people
who inhabit this world are not their own
they are manipulated frauded and pushed
by forces beyond their control our
understanding a moral being with unseen
form masquerade as gods and devils
creating the illusion of good and evil
in the face of such beings White Walkers
and Dragons are merely more pieces on
the game board